what's going on people in this video
i'll be breaking down the entire first
half of attack on titan season 4 in
about 20 minutes or less and by the end
you'll understand what the stakes are
going into part two to make things flow
easier i'll be explaining the timeline
in chronological order so you can more
easily see how the arrival of the
volunteers directly led to aaron
infiltrating another country and
starting a civil war when he arrived
back home
in case you're wondering there won't be
any spoilers for part two of the final
season in this video as i'm only going
to be talking about things that were
revealed in the first 16 episodes so as
long as you've seen those which i'm
assuming you have then nothing in here
is a spoiler before we get into it
though i'd really appreciate if you hit
that sub button as i do explainer
content what if videos and other random
stuff that you'll likely be interested
in if you're watching this okay so
following the end of attack on titan
season 3 the cervical's victory against
the warriors caused shockwaves around
the world with other countries finding
out that mali had lost the colossal and
female titans the malian empire already
had a ton of enemies before this so now
that they've been weakened by the scouts
some of those enemies saw this as a
great opportunity the story goes that
nations in the middle east instantly
formed an alliance to try and take mali
down and in the year 850 this would be
the start of a brand new war
moving on to the year 851 mali sent a
small feat of survey ships to gather
intellon parodies because they didn't
have time to launch a serious invasion
with everything going on within hours of
approaching the shore the entire fleet
had been ambushed by the attack titan
and the rest of the scouts who'd been
expecting molly's return for the past
year
as the new commander of the survey corps
hanji was excited to use this visit from
mali as a chance to learn more about the
outside world and luckily for her there
were two soldiers happy to tell her
anything she wanted to know the soldiers
i'm referring to are yelena and
onyankapon who were both forced to join
the malian army after their home
countries were invaded
as a result they had no loyalty to the
empire whatsoever and a few years ago
yelena founded a small resistance group
known as the anti-malian volunteers
according to her the goal of these
volunteers is to free the elden people
from marley's oppression but the real
plot to us here is that they were being
secretly supported by zeke yeager yelena
revealed to hanji that zeke has a plan
to guarantee the safety of parodies from
outside forces and all he's asking for
in return is that they accept him onto
the island and introduce him to eren
when this proposal was brought to the
military almost no one took it seriously
as they had zero reasons to trust the
beast titan after everything he'd done
despite that it was aaron himself who
suggested that zeke's secret plan might
be legit because the jaeger brothers
knew something that no one else did
a year ago aaron realized that if his
founding titan makes contact with the
titan of royal blood it allows him to
activate the founder's full potential
that full potential could be used to
unleash all the titans currently trapped
within the walls of parodies and trample
any nation who would try to attack them
this becomes possible if zeke's
royal-blooded beast titan is allowed to
make contact with aaron and in the
process it would guarantee the island's
safety
after hearing all this hanji understood
that zeke's proposal to meet eren might
be real but no decision was made on when
or if they'd bring him inside the walls
instead the new focus became protecting
themselves from the service ships which
marley kept on sending for years and it
was jelena who helped him to solve this
issue
by using her wireless radio she would
lure ships towards the shore at which
point they'd be ambushed by the colossal
or attack titans each time this happened
nearly all malian soldiers on board
would be locked up in a prison cause the
vast majority of them hated aldians and
didn't want to join the volunteers
over the next few months yelena and
onyankapon started to assist the island
in different ways like when they
proposed the idea of building a port
this was the first major step in turning
parodies into a modern nation and during
construction the tension between certain
prisoners and albions began to decrease
with a quick example being how chef
nicolo started to like sasha what this
proved was that malians and aliens could
get along if they got to know each other
and armin thought that this was a sign
that they could talk things out with
their enemies on the other hand aaron
thought that there wasn't enough time to
try and take this peaceful approach and
he believed that they needed to do
something to let people know they can't
be messed with
in the year 852 the port was finally
complete with the island welcoming its
first foreign visitors from the nation
of hisaru hisuru is a country in asia
that used to be friendly with aldians
around 100 years ago and after meeting
with zeke and secret they agreed to make
this trip
on her arrival ambassador kyomi revealed
the full details of zeke's plan to save
parodies which he hoped would get him
brought there as soon as possible
step one of the plan was that the jager
brothers would activate a small-scale
rumbling which would warn the rest of
the world to stay away from the island
step two of the plan is that his rule
would spend the next 50 years
modernizing parodies so that in the
future they won't have to rely on the
rumbling to survive
the third and final step was that until
this modernization is complete parodies
must always have a founding titan and a
titan of royal blood so they can still
defend themselves with the rumbling if
they have to on the face of it that plan
didn't sound too bad but the final step
is what aaron didn't like because it
meant that historia and her royal blood
would need to inherit the beast titan
after zeke's time is done only then
would they consistently maintain having
a titan of royal blood and of course in
the future historia's descendants would
also need to inherit the beast for that
same reason
although she personally seemed willing
to make this sacrifice aaron point-blank
refused to let it happen and this wasn't
the first time that he's protected her
in this way back in season 3 when he
realized how to activate the founder he
didn't tell anyone because he wanted to
avoid pretty much this exact situation
where she might be turned into a royal
blooded titan because of this aaron
rejected zeke's plan and now believe
that they had to explore other options
besides the rumbling
just before we continue it's worth
mentioning that kyomi is only here since
zeke promised her access to a valuable
natural resource from paradise called
the iceberg stone and this would make
his room incredibly rich if they were to
gain access to it another reason they
came was to see mikasa who was a
descendant of their nation's ruling
family but as cool as that sounds their
main priority is still the financial
benefits that come with having the
iceberg stone
flashing forward to the year 853 the
scouts were still desperately searching
for an alternative to zeke's plan so the
historia wouldn't need to inherit the
beast titan as a last ditch attempt to
avoid following zeke's proposal hanji
suggested that maybe the scout should
physically go to mali themselves so they
can understand the enemy and hopefully
this could be the beginning of a path to
peace i should remind you guys that at
this point in the timeline the beast
titan had less than two years to live
due to the curse of emir so if parodies
kept on wasting time then they'd lose
their chance to activate the founding
titan this is why later that same year
before the scouts went to mali yelena
convinced flock to organise a meeting
between her and eren up until now the
volunteers weren't allowed to talk to
aaron for security reasons but with
zeke's time running out it was a chance
he was willing to take
in this meeting yelena revealed
something to aaron that none of the
other volunteers knew which is that the
eldest jaeger brother doesn't actually
want to save the eldian race the reality
is that zeke's real plan ever since he
was a teenager was to find the founding
titan and use that power to sterilize
all eldians if eldians can't reproduce
then the power of the titans will
peacefully die out creating a world
where no more humans have to live in
fear of the titans and no more aldians
have to suffer in that way humanity
could be saved without the need for war
between mali and paradise but it's only
possible if the person possessing the
founding titan agrees to do this
i should also mention that zeke's true
plan does still involve doing a small
scale rumbling because that way the rest
of the world will be too afraid to
attack the island allowing the aldeans
there to peacefully die of natural
causes
while the anime didn't show us aaron's
immediate reaction to being told all of
this we did see that later in the
timeline he personally agrees to help
zeke with the euthanization plan anyway
moving on to the year 854 mali finally
won their war in the middle east after
four long years with the beast titan
wiping out the remaining enemy ships
during this battle so many aliens were
casually sacrificed by the malian army
whether that be by using them as pure
titans or as disposable soldiers i mean
they literally had a suicide squad
this kind of suffering is a thing that
elims would no longer have to go through
if zeke's dream becomes a reality which
is why in the first episode he remarks
how war is a terrible thing
in the following days after this fight a
lot of things happened as the malian
general was unhappy with the way the war
played out on at least two occasions the
armoured and beast titans were
dangerously close to being killed in
battle proving that the power of the
titans is starting to be surpassed by
technology
in response to this zeke suggested that
they should once again go to parodies to
try and steal the founder as having the
absolute power of all nine shifters
would give marley enough time to upgrade
their technology to the level of other
nations this suggestion was of course
just part of these plans to be reunited
with his brother but as it turns out
aaron wasn't too far away in episode 2
of the final season we see that aaron
had infiltrated the malian army without
permission and was in the middle east
observing reiner from a distance he
watches on as reiner interacts with
gabby and falco who were two candidates
to be the next arma titan and after
seeing this relationship aaron decides
to manipulate falco when they all return
back to mali
over the next few weeks he earns the
boy's trust by giving him a lot of
friendly advice and in return falco uses
his position as a warrior candidate to
go outside the internment zone and send
letters on aaron's behalf
due to this aaron could send highly
sensitive information to whoever he
wanted and my personal theory is that
every letter he sent was addressed to
hizru's embassy and from there kiyomi
would just pass the message on to the
relevant person
that would explain how aaron was able to
tell zeke where he was hiding in mali
with the two brothers then coming face
to face for only the second time
as i mentioned earlier it wasn't long
until they agreed to use their power to
sterilize the aldean race but crucially
the beast titan didn't want to do it
until after they got back to the island
in terms of how they actually get back
there this is where the declaration of
war comes in
for various political reasons it was a
good thing for marley to have this event
before they invaded paradise with willie
tyber using his connections to invite
diplomats and journalists from around
the world
in reality what this did was give eren
the perfect chance to hurt multiple
countries at once and he sent letters to
the scouts making it clear that he was
going to attack during the declaration
regardless of whether they helped him or
not
this was a genius move from aaron
because it created a situation where the
survey corps had no choice but to help
him because if they didn't help him then
the chances are aaron would be killed
and the rest of the world would likely
wipe out the island as revenge for what
he did
that's why in the end the scout swooped
in to save both jaeger brothers because
only these two together had the power to
stop the armies of the world who as i
mentioned would want revenge
now before we move on to everything that
happened after the declaration of war
it's worth highlighting the four main
points that came out of this battle
point number one is that aaron wiped out
all of mali's top military officials
which was done on purpose to delay the
amount of time that it would take them
to get revenge on the island for that
same reason armin also destroyed the
port because with so many of mali ships
destroyed it would take them months to
reorganize their military
point number two is that error managed
to steal the warhammer titan from lara
tiber and this was a big deal as he'd
need to use its abilities later in the
timeline
point number three is that gabby killed
sasha after sneaking aboard the airship
the scouts were using to escape and
together with falco the warrior
candidates were unexpectedly brought
back to paris island
finally point number four is that zeke
tried to fake his own death and this was
important because if marley realized
that he had betrayed them then there was
no telling what they would do in
response
on their arrival back to the island the
yeager brothers were immediately
separated with aaron being put in jail
as punishment for going rogue in mali
without permission and zeke was put
under levi's supervision in this giant
forest
considering everything that happened the
government on parodies could no longer
trust aaron and believed he might be
under his brother's control which is why
zachary began looking for new candidates
to inherit the founding titan
the volunteers who had helped the island
for the past three years were then
placed under house arrest by pixis
because if you remember they had very
close ties to zeke and at the same time
gabby and falco were locked up as
prisoners of war
as a side note the military police had
been planning for months for historia to
eat zeke as soon as he arrived on the
island however the reason this didn't
happen is because the queen had now
become pregnant her pregnancy made it
too risky for her to be titanized as
nobody knew what would happen to the
baby and as a consequence it meant that
zeke had to be kept alive until after
she gave birth this is why they put him
under levi's supervision cause if it
wasn't for his story's pregnancy zeke
would have already been eaten
briefly switching back over to the other
side of the ocean despite zeke's best
efforts to fake his death mali realized
that he had betrayed them and the
decision was made to join forces with
armies from around the world to white
parodies of the face of the earth
this new global alliance of armies would
launch their attack in six months time
as the malian army by itself was
currently too weak to do anything
despite that reiner insisted that they
couldn't wait half a year to form this
global alliance and instead he convinced
general mcgath that the warriors should
ambush the island in only one month's
time
over the next few weeks the politics on
parody started to become a lot more
complicated with the emergence of a
rebel faction known as the jaegers in
the early stages this group was led by
flock and their main aim was to bring
the two jaeger brothers into contact so
they could activate the rumbling and
secure the future of the island to
achieve this goal they did several
things starting with leaking information
to the public about how aaron had been
imprisoned when the people found out
about this it caused protests across the
country as ordinary civilians couldn't
understand why their hero was being held
hostage by the military this leak caused
support for the jaegers movement to grow
among the population and soon afterwards
flock and his team of leakers were all
sent to jail
the second major thing the yaegris did
was plant a bomb to assassinate zachary
who was the highest ranking military
officer in paradise like i said earlier
zachary was actively searching for
candidates to replace aaron as the
founding titan which is precisely the
reason why the rebels decided to get rid
of him
later that same day after zachary was
killed flock and his comrades were then
secretly released from jail by other
jaegers who worked as prison guards and
they met up with aaron who'd escaped
from prison himself using the power of
his warhammer titan together their goal
was now to find zeke and to accomplish
this they intended to kidnap someone who
knew his location
commander hanji was one of the few
people aware of where zeke was being
held and it wasn't long until she was
ambushed by the rebels and forced at
gunpoint by flock to take him to the
beast titan
speaking of the beast titan for about a
month he'd been under the watchful eye
of captain levi and 30 other soldiers
meaning it was virtually impossible for
him to try and escape or at least it
would have been if zeke didn't already
have a plan
three years ago when the first service
ships arrived he loaded these ships with
crates of wine that were contaminated
with his spinal fluid it was yelena's
mission to make sure the wine was
consumed by as many high-ranking offices
as possible and over the years this wine
actually became famous on the island
with many soldiers showing an interest
in trying it what nobody else knew was
that the wine was tainted meaning that
one screen from zeke would turn any
alien who drank it into a pure titan
unfortunately for the 30 soldiers
watching over him they'd been drinking
it ever since they arrived in the forest
as it was given to them by new survey
corps recruits who were secretly jaegers
in disguise
as a result zeke was just patiently
waiting for the day that he and aaron
agreed to meet and once that day came he
screamed at the top of his lungs
titanizing every soldier around him
except for the captain
up until now he boldly assumed that levi
wouldn't be able to kill 30 of his own
men
however when it came down to it he dealt
with them pretty quickly and soon
started chasing after zeke himself
during their fight the eldest yeager
brother was forced to transform into his
beast titan and after a brief struggle
he was blown out of his titan body by
thunderspears
as much as levi wanted to kill him in
this moment to get revenge for his
comrades and obviously evan as well he
knew he couldn't do it cause if he did
then it would all but guarantee they'd
lose the power of the beast titan for
that reason he began transporting zeke's
body back to the walls and tied the
guide to a thundersphere to make sure he
wouldn't move
regardless of that zeke still decided to
take his chances and by moving his neck
he detonated the spear blowing up
himself levi and his innocent horse in
the process
the sound of this blast was heard by
flock and hanji who were on their way to
the forest and after hearing this noise
flock decided to change directions so
they could go and investigate
meanwhile as zeke was close to death a
vision of a young girl appeared to him
and he was soon approached by one of the
pure titans he created earlier this
titan then unusually ripped open its own
stomach and put what was left of zeke's
body inside making this the last time we
saw him for the first half of the season
switching back to what was happening
inside the walls falcon and gabby were
on the run after escaping from prison
but were eventually given a place to
stay by a nice family in the countryside
in a strange twist of fate this turned
out to be sasha's family aka the person
who gabby had killed on the airship but
for now nobody realized that connection
sasha's adopted sister kaio was the only
person who knew falco and gabby were
from mali and she tried to help them get
back home by introducing them to nicolo
i briefly mentioned this earlier but
nikola was a malian chef who had a huge
crush on sasha and after her death he
invited her family to come and taste his
food when they eventually went to the
restaurant kaia made sure to bring the
two warrior candidates so they could
meet him however things took a dark turn
when nicolo realized that gabby was the
warrior candidate from the airship in
the scuffle that followed a drop of
zeke's tainted wine entered falco's
mouth meaning that if the beast titan
was to scream anywhere near him he would
be turned into a pure titan as if this
wasn't enough sasha's family were then
told that gabby was the one who killed
their daughter and mika certain armin
took her into a different room to
de-escalate the situation
this is when one of my favorite moments
in the entire season happened because
aaron who would not long escape from
prison just casually walks into the room
to have a chat with his
childhood during the following
conversation he just spent time roasting
them both for having no free will as he
claimed that mikasa only protects him
due to her ackman programming while
armin is being controlled by the
memories he inherited from bertolt
from the language he was using it was
clear from the beginning that he was
trying to upset them and later on jon
suggests that there might have been some
hidden meaning behind it
anyhow after aaron beats arm into a pulp
he then gets his soldiers to arrest
everyone in the restaurant including
sasha's family and they're all taken to
shiganshina to be imprisoned
by this point in time the yagaris now
have full control over the military as
all the high-ranking officials had to
surrender after finding out that they'd
been poisoned by zeke's spinal fluid
until this moment pixis had actually
been plotting to steal the founding
titan from aaron to stop the jagras from
rising but when the wine situation was
revealed high-ranking soldiers began to
defect to the aegiris to avoid being
titanized this left him with literally
no other option but to surrender and so
pixies gave up and agreed to all the
demands the aegis were making
now as i mentioned earlier reiner had
convinced marley to launch a quick
surprise attack on parodies and in the
lead-up to this attack peak and porco
snuck inside the walls
we know they used pete's car titan to
get there because it was implied that
her footprints were discovered leading
to aaron realizing that there was spies
on the island that's why in this scene
he wanted gabby to help him find the
undercover warriors but before he could
finish his proposal pique shows up out
of nowhere and stabs a nearby guard
it's important to realize that in this
moment her mission is not to kill eren
but rather her orders were to lure him
to a location where the founding titan
could be eaten for that reason she
attempted to earn his trust by
pretending she was defecting from mali
and she offered to show erin where her
comrades were hiding naturally he had no
real grounds to believe anything she was
saying but because he was now in control
of the situation he at least allowed
pique the chance to point out where poco
and reina might be hiding what aaron
didn't know was that porker was already
in the building disguised as a member of
the scouts bringing us to the final
spectacle from the first half of the
season with aaron on the roof the draw
titan burst out from underneath to try
and eat the founding titan and if he had
succeeded then marley would have won
right there and then
luckily for aaron only his legs got
bitten off so he was able to use that
injury as the catalyst for his
transformation
the lightning and smoke alerted nearby
malian airships to his location and on
board these ships were reiner general
mcgath and also falco's older brother i
didn't really find time to mention colt
in the video until now but like i said
he's falco's older brother and was the
warrior candidate selected by marley to
be the next beast titan well until zeke
betrayed them
anyway people if you enjoyed this recap
then i'd appreciate if you hit that sub
button as i plan to be doing episode
breakdowns for part two of the final
season and if you're feeling generous
then do be sure to smash that like
button as well
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out